- Welcome to the show.
This is hilarious.
Meet Scarlet.
Have y'all met before?
- I have not met Scarlett
Johansson before.
I have just watched her on award shows,
periodically saving
the universe, you know?
- [Kelly] Yes.
- Thank you for your service.
- My pleasure.
- So what's the ambassador
prune thing. What?
- Okay, so I am from a little farm town
in Northern California
that is the prune capital of the world.
And when you are sort of like
a "thinky," liberal, gay guy
you don't always get to
have a great relationship
with your conservative little farm town.
- Okay.
- So I would periodically
just tweet at the California Prune Board,
"I should be your unofficial,
official ambassador."
And then finally I said, "Hey,
if you guys don't respond
I'm taking my talents to the
California Cling Peach Board."
They were like, "Fine.
We give in, you can be our ambassador."
- [Kelly] Here's the thing.
I don't think I've ever had a prune.
- Prunes are delicious.
They are jamming.
They are sophisticated.
French people go crazy for them.
Am I right, Scarlett Johansson?
- Oui, absolutely.
- [Crew member] Take a pack?
- We put together a lovely
prune sampler for you guys.
- Oh my goodness.
- Wait a minute, can I ask you a kind of
like a question that I
should probably know?
- [Guy] Absolutely.
- Is a prune...it's a plum right?
- In California, like a
prune is just a dried plum.
- Oh, I love plums.
- And like everybody loves plums.
Everybody understands like an apricot.
It just turns into a dried apricot
but they get weirded out when
you go from plum to prune.
- Oh.
- And it's just
the same delicious
flavor but concentrated.
- Okay. You're a great ambassador.
- I love prunes.
I'm sorry.
I'm really proud of my little farm town.
We produce tons of almonds and peaches.
- [Kelly] I love all those.
- It's a great place.
I just wish it were more
okay to be, you know,
gay or a woman or a person of color there.
(Kelly laughing loudly)
- That was an enormous amount of people.
(Guy laughing boisterously)
- [Kelly] So wait, you're also an author.
Here we go.
So "My Life as a Goddess."
Where did this come from?
Why'd you wanna do this?
(audience clapping)
- I just, I had this
story that I would always
tell my friends.
There's a story from Greek
mythology about a lady,
a goddess, who was pregnant,
but didn't have a husband.
And people were like mean
to her and made fun of her.
And she like got like mad and
pissed off and walked away.
And then she was like,
"Oh, wait, I'm a goddess,"
and then turned around and
turned them all into frogs.
And I think that that's an
important thing to remember is
that you have amazing powers.
Like we all have amazing
powers that we can use.
And when you're down on
yourself, you need to
remember to use those powers
in whatever way you can.
- [Kelly] And don't give it away.
- Don't give it away.
- Yeah. I love that they all are frogs.
(Kelly and Guy laughing)
So you, you said this a while back.
Some people just need to find a path
to being comfortable
with themselves enough
that they can be comfortable
with people around.
I love this quote because
I think that's so true.
Until you're comfortable with
yourself and in your own skin,
how, first of all can anybody
else be comfortable with you?
And then also it's reciprocal.
I love this.
Why do, why do you think this?
- I think it's so real
that anytime somebody has
a weird relationship
to your specificities,
for me so frequently
being gay and very fat.
And it's like, that's not about me.
That's about them.
You know, it's about their
issues with themselves.
And I think that one of
the best things we can do
for other people is respect ourselves
and our own specificities enough
to be able to respect theirs.
And that's really what this
movie "Bros" is about is
like two white, cis gay
guys who have developed
like protective mechanisms for dealing
with a homophobic world
who don't realize how
much those protective mechanisms
are hurting themselves
and the people around them and
then learning to like chill
out and have fun and be
comfortable with themselves.
- Yeah.
- But also,
as I was saying before, Kelly Clarkson
I have to tell you
- Okay.
- Thank you so much
for how much you have taken
care of me on dance floors.
So many times in my life when
I needed you, you showed up.
- Well, you're gonna love the next album.
(laughs boisterously)
- [Kelly] Wait. So most, most of the cast
in production team of
"Bros" were LGBTQ, right?
- [Guy] Yes.
- [Kelly] That's important.
- [Guy] The entire cast,
whether they're playing
straight people or queer
people or trans people
or LGBTQ plus.
We have a couple of
cameos from iconic divas,
who I believe are part
of the plus in LGBTQ+
you know, you guys have given us so much
and we owe so much back to you.
- I love you so much.
Okay. So wait, we know
that Scarlett is really
into music, and you're great
at hosting a game show.
So like, what if we did a game
like a music game and you host
it, would you be into this?
- I mean, that sounds really fun.
- Okay, I'm into it. Okay.